[Music]
[Music]
tell me a little bit about the the hall
of fame tell me about the whole thing
you know halloween i'm born how you the
hall of fame at 22. come on
man
i'm coming one day
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to this
episode of hot boxing with mike tyson
i'm your co-host triple c aka henry
cejudo and i'm mike tyson man we got
[ __ ] polo g in here man gang
so talk to us polo man you're from
chinatown when you start doing this man
you 22 now you said yeah i just turned
22
in january how long have you been doing
this
like uh i first started rapping i could
remember i made my first rap when i was
like nine
i went to the studio for the first time
when i turned 17.
i shot my first video at 18
and i got signed
approaching three years ago how did you
get discovered but
i want to know [ __ ] is happening good
for you where's the hard times
i'm used to rapidly that [ __ ] with all i
can get through couldn't get signed
now it kind of happened fast though
because oh [ __ ]
because it was really like me utilizing
youtube to my advantage on uh social
media like i was on facebook heavy to
gain the fan base starting out
so you're learning the [ __ ] letter
face
book [ __ ] has got me [ __ ] up
yeah you know you hear show your faith
do some crazy [ __ ] and 100 million
people know you
yeah a little bit like that ain't that a
trip but i think i think in his
generation mike like these guys are more
uh it's just it's a different attention
right it's a different gravitation to
the eye that's what they have been able
to master at a for their for their
generation am i right yeah for sure
tell me about your brothers and sisters
you have an older sister right
yeah i got i got one older sister she 24
and then i got a younger brother he
about 16 he'd be rapping too his name
trend he's in your crew though
he got his own crew yeah you could say
that we we gonna sign with the same crew
that's my brother
sister doing any rapping any kind of
music yeah my sister do music
too but she ain't really dropped the
first song again my my brother got music
on youtube he ain't helping this [ __ ]
yeah yeah i'll be um pushing her to get
in the studio
she just like her own biggest critic you
know but she the one
reason i do music i used to look up to
her doing it and um i got a younger
sister too her name leia
she's about eight years old oh [ __ ]
little baby yeah
since you got how many awards you ever
win the one the choice awards with the
kids and all that stuff
now as far as the wars go i ain't no i
never want none never been sauce awards
and all that stuff yeah no nothing
that's coming your way soon for sure
talk to me about the chain on your neck
man 13. 1300
this the block i'm from from 1300 block
up north on the north side of chicago
everybody know that too huh
yeah look good
because i've been watching i'm kind of
curious i don't know if you've seen it i
think we talked about it mike you ever
seen that you ever seen a tv show called
the the shy
yeah that was fly i watched like an
episode or two before but i never got
into i don't really watch tv the show is
really fly
i i think it could be good but i think
it's i don't know you know obviously
you're from chicago but this takes place
i think in particular the south side if
you don't see where he's going he just
think he's going to be hip-hop but you
gonna be in movies and [ __ ] no y'all
wanna act one day it's just like right
now i'm too shy for that that's what
you're gonna do though okay
ain't you just gonna happen you'll be
acting rapping
acting like you're
[Laughter]
the
rapping
who were uh who were some of your
biggest influences as a as a rapper man
that you uh that you admire and that
that have inspired you you know to come
up with your own flows and things like
that your swagger
wayne of course
i just actually released a song with him
like a week ago uh one
it's going crazy on that it's called
game game
okay let's let's see it what's up pull
it up i forgot
[Laughter]
and then uh anybody outside of that i
could say just the chicago uprise in
general
[Music]
i'm just trying to put a lock on the
game
[Music]
keep at least 200 on me keep at least
like 30 rounds on me but my [ __ ] to
the wheels fall off don't
this video dude it's well produced bro
this thing is fire that's some budget
huh [ __ ]
yeah
hey my label no they got this my wife
said my wife saw your commercial
he got budget
what's up
yeah
that is quality
my wife used to be wardrobe for these
guys the rappers and stuff she's doing
the
oh yeah
yeah that's cool man with these videos
do you guys uh this is a little movie
one of the miniature movies yeah but i
wanted do you guys choreograph this
stuff or do you kind of just you just go
with the beating whatever you feel you
kind of you know you mimic or you do it
depends on how into the song i am like
and i'm not just i'm gonna say like i
ain't got none of my songs that i put
out that i don't like but it's like the
ones that i hold closer to me like it
had a deeper meaning behind it i got a
vision behind it too but nobody's going
to say hey do it like this right
no no yeah nobody's instructing you how
to do this right yeah not necessarily
that can give me pointers but most
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how was the filming for this bro was it
fun dude those are the fun experiences
you're having huh right now like
reaching success is doing a
video with lil wayne and things like
that hell yeah it was fun it was like
really not until i got back home
like i noticed how surreal it was to be
doing a video with wayne like i was just
sitting there like i used to hang out
with these guys in louisiana i know he
was 16 years old he didn't say a word
i can't stop him from talking
but uh uh tupac he was another big
inspiration tupac was one of mike's good
friends
yeah
yeah i i i really didn't get up on to
tupac until i was older
like probably like at my teenage
and then that's when i started to really
discover like what he was about
you you have you have four hundred
million
streams on spotify right
man how do you feel about that everybody
clocking you every move
i mean it's something that i work
towards i really like more so humble
about it though what what's the song
that really roger's name like do you
have your number one man that you really
uh
that kind of speaks to your heart
a lot my favorite song of mine right now
is uh epidemic
epidemic let's play that [ __ ]
yeah that's probably the favorite
something
what's what's behind that one that uh
because you're you're a poet man like
you know what i'm saying you you know
it's not just about you
yeah i don't really like i can't really
put my finger on it feel like i just
spoke my mind and this was in the middle
of the quarantine like when a uh when
the pandemic first started
oh no i really just spoke my mind
[Music]
i'm so sick of farewells and rrp and the
trenches y'all ain't gang gang mom ties
what i bleed don't claim to be a hop
cause [ __ ] die from that disease he
gonna let that now blow it
can i speak my mind can i breathe i know
she might cry if i leave i've been
fooled by liars and thieves i stopped my
role but i know time cannot freeze once
you get my [ __ ] up
this is fly hanging out with your crew
designer gear on
where's the set this
do you direct this yeah as far as like
sentence
yes and that thing yeah i put that
together but it's like um i really been
doing that since i started rapping
though because
early on
i used to um do the management like
handle my own management and i didn't
really have nobody helping me at all so
i just go do all my videos and
everything on my own your first fight
mike the first place 500 bucks
500
has a pro
and a heavyweight jesus man but how you
only make 500. i really made nothing
somebody took 500 bucks out of their
pocket and gave it to me
but i just love fighting i would fight
for nothing
and they can't want the world to see me
because once they see men they're gonna
start paying for me yeah yeah
yeah but then again the flip side that
that 500
turned into a whole lot more than that
oh absolutely
for sure who was your biggest payday
mike i had quite a few yeah
like 35
35
that's a lot of money
yeah but i make that now i'm 55 [ __ ]
that's back in the 90s too so that would
be like almost like 100 maybe maybe
close to you know what i'm saying what
would that mean equivalently
we still doing this
doing this g
they're trying to write us off can't get
rid of me gee
they can't get rid of me
i saw they did a story about that's all
those haters and it's also jealous of me
gee
because the girl being
look what i'm doing
i'm talking to you on my show
i'm talking to you
yeah yeah this is
going to tell you so
you do a little bit of philanthropy too
huh you brought in the aau into the city
of chicago
tell me about the aau hell yeah um
i started my team i'm really funny to
get back in the field with my team this
summer the corona is slowed that thing
down but i had an athlete
i used to uh play basketball a little
when i was uh
coming up
but um i had visited my um childhood
school and they told me they ain't have
an aau team
so that's when i put it together had
tryouts a lot of the kids from my
neighborhood i sent out flies made sure
they came
and we kick-started it like that
how many teams do you have
i got a section for the younger kids and
then a section for the older kids in
high school
and then some for like middle schoolers
and stuff like that it's just split up
into two really but it's still within
all under the same thing
i respect it that's what we should do
that's what everybody should do that's
what god created us to do to help
everyone for sure tell me a little bit
about the the hall of fame
tell me about the whole thing you know
hall of fame
i'm going to be high in the hall of fame
at 22 come on man
i'm going to be one day that's what i'm
really 22. i think you're talking about
what what are you talking about
no i'm talking about one of his albums
man yeah the world hall of fame yeah
that's my album oh it's really like me
speaking in its own existence
yeah i just speak into existence all the
time mike i was gonna ask you mike are
you uh you're inducted to the hall of
fame
wrestling in boxing oh yeah wrestling
too
[Music]
screaming money counting shanks clanking
[ __ ] i guess decided
i ain't joking do it sound like i'm
kidding i've been making like 2 000 a
minute so high up through the clouds i
was swimming i'm probably gonna drown
when i'm in it i bet she gonna
[Music]
know any of those girls for real
no
now i will be helping my friend she will
be my friend forever
yes forget these people what are you
doing you have to get these people
and i try to stay away from that
you're the disciplined entertainer but
your money and business huh
yeah
that's what it's about handling your
business i'm just talking [ __ ] about the
good about handling your business for
sure that you know how many people will
be looking at you on this [ __ ] ain't
nothing like flying private too
huh
yeah i wasn't i thought i was gonna say
i wasn't on the set but i actually was
on the plane for that i'm playing
commercial you could see people talk to
people fighting private you know you
know with your friends everybody's
sleeping and eating yeah
so you saying like you like being with
the people more yeah
i don't like that i talk [ __ ] to them
and stuff
it's like on a private plane the people
are too much in my business i don't like
people in my bed don't like the the lady
what do you call against the stories
i don't think they don't this in a small
place for a few hours in the in your
business you don't feel congested when
that happens
i feel like the the commercial flight
they just as much in your business no i
can't see him i could see so many
different people instead of seeing four
people me and my wife and my kids
yeah yeah i know there's nothing like
that i've actually i've flown private
with you mike yeah remember you're
scolding us on our way from uh florida
back to no on the way to minnesota why
do
you're scolding us on relationships
i'm somebody that should talk holy god
you can learn what not to do in your
relationship for me you can't learn what
to do
i don't know but that day you were
scolding us but all of us were just
sitting there like all right
so what are you planning man what are
you doing with your life
look i got hall of fame on the way
dropping it june 11th
and i just really been uh
trying to hone in on getting better as a
rapper over the summer what girl rapper
you like to do a song with
nicki minaj yeah she's really cold yeah
do you like you know her mike i met her
before i don't know i said hi
she said hi
there's a lot man can we pull up the
goat
yeah let's check the coat out
see my mom he said you know messing up
those girls because they're trouble
right
yeah
yeah
i mean saying that he's a smart man
[Music]
we did
things when you
[Music]
[Music]
he was playing games got you dancing in
the middle of the club got you dancing
in the middle of the club i know what
you chasing you can only get this
feeling from a thug you can only get
this feeling from a thought tears
falling and it's licking your cup all
you really want is love baby all you
man i'm trying to get to know you
sexually
damn he [ __ ] you up
that's like the um the martin episode
when he fought
how much do you think you've evolved
mike obviously he's 22 years old you
talk about your shot but then i see your
video i'm like man you could you know
you'd be a good actor too bro yeah
possibly i feel like uh anything that i
have something to do with it like i try
to damn near perfected yeah you do a
good job doing that you know i was
talking too i was a real [ __ ]
the nice kid
my kid
but how old were you mike when you won
your first world title 20 20.
yeah
you're still the youngest in history
right mike yeah it's this
yeah it's not steve 20 years old
oh it's what we got to do man let's get
our man out of here man yeah that's
what's up man any advice mike any any
closing thoughts for him that you would
uh that you would give us listen i think
he's doing everything just as
good as i can ever tell you everything
looks good man
for sure he don't like to talk his
business and stuff but you know honestly
everything looks good
any last messages apollo g you're
talking to millions of people please no
it's good though hall of fame on the way
back y'all know what the [ __ ] going on
you know what the [ __ ] going on hall
of fame [ __ ]
okay
that's it i'm triple c
hey i'm mike tyson
bingo capilot
polo with the jizzy
we out
[Music]
you